joe biden is giving up and going to the
beach the president has no events today
and instead is in delaware for a holiday
getaway while omicron spikes all across
the country now back when he was a
candidate biden promised to shut down
the virus then once he was president he
bashed gop governors for not doing
enough
the administration's failure on testing
is colossal
and it's a failure of planning
leadership and execution
we will deal honestly with the american
people
and we'll never ever ever quit
that's how we'll shut down this virus
i'm going to shut down the virus
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm going to shut down the virus need to
scale up testing so anyone who needs one
can get a test
after 10 months of the pandemic we still
don't have enough testing
that's a travesty
some state officials are passing laws or
signing orders
that forbid people
from doing the right thing but you
aren't going to help at least get out of
the way
now the president is singing a much
different tune saying there's not really
much you can do
look there is no
federal solution this gets solved at a
state level i'm looking at governor
sununu on the board here he talks about
that a lot
and it ultimately gets down to
where the rubber meets the road and
that's where the patient is in need of
help or preventing the need for help
but people all across the country still
don't have access to covet tests and
they're stuck waiting hours in line when
maybe it didn't have to be this way
under president trump you had three
major tests approved by next now by
abbott quidell
and b.diverator those are the two three
main ones that are out there now those
home tests guess what just got approved
the roach test just got approved one
year into the biden administration one
year and that's a terrific home test and
it finally got an emergency use
authorization but was stalled in front
of the fda under the biden
administration so the blame game doesn't
work and and for sure president biden
has to say what did president trump get
right
well i'm going to start with you joey
because the failures of this
administration have been very personal
for you of course i'm talking about the
humiliating um exit from afghanistan
and and the needless death that was
caused in that situation but here we are
he said he was going to have the test we
don't have the test any and he also
complained about the other president not
having the test and we don't have the
test joey you know it feels like maybe
somebody just played joe biden's words
for joe biden and he listened hey just
get out of the way and uh and let if
you're not going to help get out of the
way and let those that will do it and
that's what he's doing he's going to go
to he's going to go on vacation and some
governors are going to step in and do
the right thing i hope
it really is amazing i mean can you
imagine the billboards that will pop up
in places like my hometown in dalton
georgia it's just going to be joe
biden's big face and it's going to say
there is no federal solution there is
nothing president joe biden can do by
his own words to help in any of these
any of these things we're struggling
with from inflation to like you said
what happened in afghanistan to what's
happening at the border and now
coronavirus i just don't know how i
don't know how you work for this man and
not just hang your head in shame when he
sits up there and he says something like
that i mean he's got a staff there it's
working every day i think they they're
honest in their work any and he really
has just taken the air out of their out
of their balloon i don't know how they
keep going to work every day at this
point
nicole uh let me start with you too
because you're a doctor you're my friend
but you're a doctor too
i have a question about omicron that's
just on my mind as i see all this play
out omicron is is very virulent it
spreads rapidly but it appears to not be
deadly so explain to me why this
wouldn't be a great opportunity to kind
of let it rip through the population and
get hurt immunity
well rachel first of all out of all the
global data from south africa uk
scotland others including the united
states there is a lot of information
that is suggesting that the virulence of
omicron is much less with the much lower
hospitalization rate anywhere from 40 to
80 percent less than we saw with delta
and preceding earlier variants now that
it doesn't mean that it's not as
contagious it's actually much more
contagious much more transmissible which
is why we're seeing such a high rise of
cases right now but you know in terms of
should we just let it rip and it's a
fine line rachel and first of all you
know by doing that and by letting things
just go unchecked in the population you
will have preventable illness
preventable hospitalizations and
preventable death however i wrote a
piece on foxnews.com a couple of weeks
ago that was met with criticism because
i said at this point in the pandemic we
have the vaccines we have boosters we
have a large amount of natural immunity
and we finally have a variant that yes
is highly contagious but seems to be
more mild especially more mild in people
who are fully vaccinated and people who
are boosted so people have the tools at
this point to prevent infection and if
they do get infected infected it tends
to be more mild less serious and now we
finally have treatments that are proving
effective so yes getting that hybrid
immunity that vaccine-induced immunity
plus a breakthrough infection so some
level of natural immunity that is by far
the strongest wave of protection that we
could have moving forward and this could
be our step into making this virus
become endemic and that is how the
mindset needs to change i'm glad
president biden has finally realized
that it will not be a black and white
federal solution i remember i'm old
enough to remember when president trump
said a couple of years ago this needs to
be on the onus needs to be on the states
it is the federal government's job to
secure these private public partnerships
and get out of the way and that is
exactly what operation warp speed did
they allowed people to get that private
public partnership get things to the
market and unfortunately we're not
seeing the same urgency under the biden
administration
well you're so right doctor because
president trump said from the very
beginning that states should be allowed
to do what they think is right for their
state
so richard now seems like the biden
administration is agreeing with trump on
this do you agree that this is no this
should have always been a state solution
well a couple things here number one i
do think that it has to be a mixture of
both the federal government and the
state government working together to
ensure that people get supplies folks
get ventilators as you saw at the
beginning of the pandemic when hospital
when when states were searching for
ventilators it was on the federal
government to make sure they had those
ventilators but with that being said
what i really hate is these the
president's on vacation headlines right
we saw this this is this headline
rears it ugly head every single year it
happened under george w bush it happened
under barack obama it happened under
donald trump it happened under the white
house and i think the american people
are smarter than that they know wherever
the president goes so goes the white
house both the white house
communications office all the necessary
advisors the president needs to have on
hand to make decisions the nuclear
football military everything moves when
the president moves so this headline
that news of outlets continue to put out
there it's just so misleading and it's
so ridiculous
yeah i actually agree with you richard i
think that you know with technology the
president couldn't go wherever he's at
now if the president's not in good shape
mentally that's another issue it doesn't
matter where he's at in that case
tyrus let me go to you because the
president's top covet advisor is dr
fauci as we know and he's saying we need
to cancel new year's i'm hosting new
years for fox news we're not canceling
what do you think
well as someone who gets to stay home
for new year's cancel away no i'm just
kidding it's wrong you know the only
thing that i is refreshing is that the
president finally did throw his hands up
and said
we dropped the ball there's nothing we
can do on the federal level
it's up to the uh governors and state
and i'm kind of at least give me that
because we've heard nothing but nonsense
coming out of the federal government
under this administration since they
came in they were going to do all this
other stuff and here's the the part that
drives me absolutely mad is they they've
wanted all of us to act like we're in
remember when we were kids it was like
code orange and code red and it was it's
been covered orange covid pretty much
since the administration took over
but they still ran on a test which means
that
on the surface you're telling us it's
terrible but in the closed doors you're
saying don't worry about it we can go on
vacations we can we'll just lower the
cdc you know from ten days to five days
if so we can make up for not having
testing because federal workers can't go
back to work unless they have a a
negative uh test on their on their
covert test if they get covet so they're
continually changing it's like a rubik's
cube where someone peels the stickers
off that's what this administration is
doing they just put new stickers around
saying look we solved the rubik's cube
and no you didn't it's a hot mess get it
together yeah i love that yeah
they definitely look like they're making
it up as they go along hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else